talking of all you perverts it was a big
year it was a big year for pedophile
movies surviving r.kelly
leaving Neverland to Pope's shadow
shadow I don't care I don't care you
probably know me as the creator of the
office no you don't do you you think
Steve Carell did you know oh he's
brilliant isn't he Steve Carell he's
amazing as the bumbling office manager
where does he get his ideas from
let's pay hundreds of millions of
dollars and put them in every movie if
you can't be bothered to go to the
cinema to see Steve in action then just
watching might be Thursday here on NBC
[Applause]
honestly I like a drink as much the next
man unless the next man is Mel Gibson
[Applause]
our first presenter is beautiful
talented and Jewish apparently Mel
Gibson told me that he's obsessed
please welcome Scarlett Johansson you
could binge watch the entire first
season of afterlife instead of watching
the show that that's a show about a man
who wants to kill himself because his
wife dies of cancer and it's still more
fun than this okay
spoiler alert season two is on the way
so in the end he obviously didn't kill
himself just like Jeffrey Epstein shut
up I know he's your friend but I don't
care
joy and trainwreck no not the names of
Charlie Sheen's two favorite hookers the
films of our next two presenters their
best friends by the way they wanted me
to tell you that and if you forget they
said they they'd tweet you and Ramona
basically they're there come round and
shout we threw their best friend it's
like they've never had a friend before
please welcome Amy Schumer and Jennifer
Lawrence
[Music]
at least jeffrey tambor did it in a
dress what a year he's had oh what an
actor what a role no it's every day he
has to put on all that women's clothes
and the hair and makeup and let people
film it that takes balls so I don't know
how he does it
I really don't I've seen his balls
they're huge and long either if he
tucked him in the bra does I think when
you push him out the back and let him
hang out like a bulldog no one knows I
love Jeffrey Tambor I don't know if
that's because he's such a great actor
or because he reminds me of my nan let's
get on with it before NBC replaced me
with Jay Leno
once upon a time in Hollywood nearly
three hours long Leonardo DiCaprio
attended the premiere and by the end his
date was too old for him on a serious
note just looking at all the faces here
reminds me of some of the great work
that's been done this year by cosmetic
surgeons talking of the walking dead
congratulations to Hugh Hefner who was
getting married at the age of 84 to
24-year old beauty Crystal Harris when
she was asked why she was marrying him
she said because he lied about his age
he told me he was 94 oh come on
don't worry hold out and just just don't
look at it when you touch it
ask them
[Applause]
our next presenters are two of the
funniest people in America she stole the
show on Saturday Night Live then went on
to create write and star their own show
30 rock he was a job in actor career not
going that well if I'm being totally
honest who-who got his big break when I
cast him in a remake of a show that I
created called the office he's now
leaving that show and killing a cash cow
for both of us please welcome the
wonderful Tina Fey and the ungrateful
Steve
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
listen if you do win tonight remember
that no one cares about that award as
much as you do
okay don't get emotional it's
embarrassing okay
that award is no offense worthless it's
a bit of metal that some nice old
confused journalists wanted to give you
in person so they could meet you and
have a selfie with you okay that's all
it is
I've got three I've got three Golden
Globes myself so I can set ones a
doorstop when I use to hit burglars with
and when I keep by the bed - doesn't
matter why it's mine it's mine it's mine
I won it fair and square
it's just the right shape and size it's
nothing
yeah so to be clear that was a joke
about me shoving golden globes that I've
won up my ass the next presenter is an
award-winning actress with special
powers in Die Another Day she used her
powers of seduction to win over James
Bond in x-men she used her powers to
control the elements in Catwoman she
used the power of being able to wash
herself all over and she's the poor for
behind-the-ear it's brilliant
please welcome the very clean Halle
Berry a few years ago on this show I
made a joke about Mel Gibson getting a
bit drunk and saying a few unsavory
things we've all done it
I wasn't judging him but now I find
myself in the awkward position of having
to introduce him again listen I'm sure
it's embarrassing for both of us okay
and I blame NBC for this terrible
situation now blames we know Mel Banks
[Laughter]
[Applause]
listen I still feel a bit bad for it
right Mel's forgotten all about it
apparently that's what drinking does
I want to say somewhat nice about Mao
before he comes out so oh yeah okay here
go I'd rather have a drink with him in
his hotel room tonight
than with Bill Cosby please Malcolm now
Gibson
[Applause]
[Applause]
yeah I love seeing Ricki once every
three years because it reminds me to get
a colonoscopy
yeah
well if you'd left your drink you don't
need to leave your drink here I'll put
you to sleep another way son a little
bit listen
yes can I ask you a question go ahead I
think we all wanting out of this I don't
know that's the guy that said it it
wasn't me
all female remakes are the big thing
there's a female remake of ghostbusters
there's going to be a female remake of
Ocean's eleven and this is brilliant for
the studios because they get guaranteed
box office results and they don't have
to spend too much money on the cast so
[Applause]
shut up I don't care
but actors aren't just loved here in
Hollywood they I loved the world over
because they're recognizable you can be
anyone you could be in the third world
okay and you get a glimpse of a
Hollywood star and it makes you feel
better okay you could be a little a
little child a little asian child with
no possessions and no money but you get
a you see a picture of Angelina Jolie
and you think mummy
[Applause]
if you win right come up except Giuliana
ward
thank your agent and your God and off
okay our next presenter is an actress
who is both beautiful and talented born
in England she came to America and has
taken Hollywood by storm the star of the
nominated movie the Danish girl please
it's a dude Eddie Redmayne
[Applause]
one thing that can't be bought is a
golden bow officially
[Applause]
I'm not gonna do this again anyway but
if you were to buy one the mantasy would
be Phillip Burke
I love this next presenter he's so cool
he's the star of Iron Man two girls and
a guy Wonder Boys sorry these porn films
what Kiss Kiss Bang Bang Bowfinger
really yeah the Academy come on
he has done all those films but many of
you in this room probably know him best
from such facilities as the Betty Ford
Clinic and Los Angeles County Jail
please welcome Robert Downey jr.
[Music]
Jennifer Lawrence made the news when she
demanded equal pay for women in
Hollywood and she received the air
overwhelming support from people
everywhere there were marches on the
street with nurses and factory workers
saying how the how could a 25 year old
live on 52 million this is but there
were plumbers around the world oh poor
girl uns Oh Rocky now so but joking
aside of course women should be paid the
same as men for doing the same job and
I'd like to say now that I'm getting
paid exactly the same as Tina and Amy
did last year posed me now I know there
was two of them but it's not my fault if
they want to share the money is it
that's their stupid bowl yeah it's funny
because it's true the Hollywood Foreign
Press deemed the Martian a comedy and
even nominated it and hence Matt Damon
is here tonight so that worked a treat
to be fair the Martian was a lot funnier
than pixels but then again so was
Schindler's List
it's just a film what can I say about
our next two presenters the first is an
actor producer writer and director whose
movies have grossed over three and a
half billion dollars at the box office
he's won two Academy Awards and three
Golden Globes for his powerful and
varied performances starring in such
films as Philadelphia Forrest Gump
castaway Apollo 13 and Saving Private
Ryan the other is Tim Allen
[Music]
it was a big year for 3d movies Toy
Story Despicable Me Tron seems like
everything this year was 3-dimensional
except the characters in The Tourist I
feel bad about that joke all right no no
I tell you why I'm jumping on the
bandwagon because I haven't even seen
the tourist who has and but no it must
be good because it's nominated so shut
up okay and I'd like to quash this
ridiculous rumor going around that the
only reason the tourist was nominated
was so the Hollywood Foreign Press could
hang out with Johnny Depp and Angelina
Jolie that is that is rubbish that is
not the only reason they also accepted
bribes
let's okay you know our next presenter
from such films as Hudson Hawk look
who's talking Mercury Rising color of
night fifth element hearts war
please welcome Ashton Kutcher's dad
Bruce Willis
there are a lot of big films that didn't
get nominated this year nothing for Sex
in the City - no I was sure the Golden
Globe for special effects would go to
the team that airbrushed that poster
great job girls we know how old you are
I saw one of you in an episode of
bonanza
[Applause]
is the star of the hilarious comedy the
Martian
[Laughter]
oh I nearly died right he's also the
only person who Ben Affleck hasn't been
unfaithful to please welcome
Matt Damon
[Applause]
shut up you disgusting pill-popping
sexual deviants come I want to do this
monologue and then go into hiding okay
not even Sean Penn will find me
[Applause]
snitch it's gonna be a night of partying
and heavy drinking
or as Charlie Sheen calls it breakfast
Wow whoa so let's get this straight
what he did was he he picked up a porn
star paid her to have dinner with him
introduced her to his ex-wife as you do
went to hotel got got drunk got naked
trashed the place
while she was locked in the cupboard and
that was a Monday what what did he do
New Year's Eve the Golden Globes is
shown all over the world it is oblivious
to color or creed
it doesn't just celebrate talent it
celebrates difference it crushes
prejudice and stereotype one stereotype
I hate is that all Irishmen are just
drunk
sweary pal razors please welcome Colin
Farrell
[Applause]
our next presenters are young and thin
with hair and teeth they're lovely to
look at which is just as well because
they're presenting the Award for Best
Foreign Language Film a category that no
one in America cares about
please welcome Olivia Wilde and Robert
Pattinson
[Applause]
also not nominated I love you Philip
Morris
Jim Jim Carrey and Ewan McGregor to
heterosexual actors pretending to be gay
so the complete opposite of some famous
Scientologists then
probably
my lawyer has helped me with a wording
of that joke they're not here okay when
brad and angelina see our next two
adorable little presenters they're gonna
want to adopt them please welcome Kevin
Hart and Ken Jeong
[Applause]
now Caitlyn Jenner of course what a year
she's had she became a role model for
trans people everywhere showing great
bravery in breaking down barriers in
destroying stereotypes she didn't do a
lot for women drivers
you can't have everything Danya not at
the same time one Hollywood publication
said that me hosting would mean that
some film stars would stay away for fear
of being made fun of as if film stars a
stay away from the chance of winning a
golden glow particularly their film
company has already paid for it
[Applause]
what's with all the divorces what's
going on
I mean Arnold Oh Maria JLo and Mark
Antony Ashton and to me Kim Kardashian
and some going no one had ever remember
he wasn't he wasn't around long 72 days
a marriage that lasted 72 days
I've sat through longer James Cameron
acceptance speeches the the Catholic
Church are furious about the film as it
exposes the fact that 5% of all their
priests have repeatedly molested
children and been allowed to continue to
work without punishment
Roman Polanski called it the best date
movie ever